did you know Teen Wolf was going to be
that big of a hit
uh well so I jumped on the third season
oh so it was already hit so it already
was a a giant hit my my story is kind of
crazy though I knew about Teen Wolf
before it ever started because I worked
with
um one of the directors who's also a
producer on the show on prayers for
Bobby he directed prayers for Bobby
Russell
um and so I auditioned for season one of
Teen Wolf
um and then I auditioned for season two
where
um for a different role where I was it
it was between me and another kid or a
couple kids but I mean I auditioned for
that one like 17 times I had Teen Wolf
17 times a ton in front of for just for
MTV and MTV wasn't behind me and they
had an offer out to Daniel Sharman
um who had just come off like a really
popular movie at the time the Immortals
I think
um and I didn't know that so they just
like it felt like they kept giving me
different notes like they're like oh
he's too edgy he needs to be more GQ or
he's got to be more nerd so like I'd go
in these auditions like dressed
completely different every time and
they'd be like and it was just smoke and
mirrors they're waiting for Daniel to
answer them and MTV didn't like me
um so yeah the third season is when I
actually got on did they offer it to you
or yeah
hey there folks it's Michael Rosenbaum
and boy have I got a huge announcement
for you this has been a long time
comment and it's finally here I'm doing
a live podcast my podcast inside of you
with Michael Rosenbaum is going live
yeah for the first time ever on
Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there uh that one
was uh no I I auditioned but it was I
was heavily favored really yeah finally
this guy's paid his dues yes like I
always had people on Teen Wolf behind me
now and and Russell for sure that's good
yeah yeah you have to have cheerleaders
you have to have somebody out there
that's rooting for you and that's so
important in life it's like having
somebody that believes in you yeah
because I owe them a lot it's hard to
believe in yourself sometimes when
nobody else does so if you have that one
person I always talk about that you know
my you're not a teacher that actually
was patient with me I remember Mr Morrow
Mr Morrow in fact I went back home in
Indiana and uh I said hey we're all
going uh taroni's for some pizza I'm
taking Everybody's Pizza why don't you
come
I'd love that
I would love to do that so old Mr Morrow
straight up and all my friends were like
what who's this is Mr Morrow
some did but like yeah yeah he was like
he was a substitute teacher thank God
for this in this one year and uh we we
hit it off he was just he's just cool
buddy you know he was he didn't like I
was stupid yeah exactly and it means the
world when you're a kid you know like
just someone to that you connect with or
that you know doesn't treat you like a
child yeah it means a lot when you're a
kid so you get the role and I know MTV
and a lot of these streamers I I I I
assume to be is probably pretty cheap
um but MTV money I remember I did a show
and I mean uh guys I'm telling you I got
this pilot for MTV with Jackson browne's
son Ethan great guy and Leslie Bibb
and the three of us did this show
and I was paid four thousand dollars for
the pilot
sounds about right and after taxes and
everything was about for three four
weeks I I think I had fourteen hundred
dollars yeah
and then yeah so I know and then they
wanted me to do a development deal
because uh the pilot didn't go but they
liked me we'll give you five grand I'm
like whoa
yeah I'm rich that's what I thought but
I mean
were you like was it the same same story
MTV does not they're not known for
paying well but did they start to pay
you in season four and season five I
mean or was it just never a thing about
money with that show they no they were
it was tough always battle even the
actors that were there from the
beginning were battling and MTV's just
not so the cool thing though with MTV
that we got lucky with is
um like the CW for instance uh
conventions you know like the fans are
so strong and so powerful that doing
these conventions pays good money
um and so that's where the money comes
to get that keeps on giving yeah with
Teen Wolf we could do conventions with
Teen Wolf named whatever like we could
they uh like the arrow ones or like ones
for CW it's always like bow and arrow or
like something that's not nothing to do
with Teen Wolf but it's like similar you
know right whereas for whatever MTV
didn't have any of those restrictions on
us so you know we did well in
conventions if we were able to get away
from work